hello in this series of presentations
I'm going to try to teach you everything
you need to know about triangles and and
angles and parallel lines and this is
probably the highest yield information
that you could ever learn especially in
terms of a standardized test and then
when we've learned all the rules we'll
play something that I called the angle
game which is essentially what the SAT
makes you do over and over again so
let's start with some basics well you
know what an angle is well actually
maybe you don't know what an angle is
and I'll tell you what an angle is an
angle if I have two lines let me draw a
thicker line than that if I have two
lines and they intersect at some point
the angle is a measure of exactly kind
of how how wide the intersection is
between those two lines so it's like let
me use a better tool so this is the
angle an angle is is how wide those two
lines kind of open up and they're
measured either in degrees or radians
and and for the sake of most of a
geometry class will use it degrees and
that's in when we start doing
trigonometry you learn radians or maybe
you could learn it now and you're
probably familiar with this you know a
very small zero degrees would be these
two lines on top of each other this if I
were to just eyeball it looks like I
don't know like 45 degrees if I had the
lines even wider apart like that that's
90 degrees and a 90 degree lines are
also called perpendicular because they
are well I feel like saying because they
are perpendicular but because one is
going completely vertical while the
other is going horizontal they're going
in in they well it's actually amazingly
difficult to find the exact right
wording but I think you get the idea
there by definition perpendicular lines
have a 90 degree apart from each other
and you know you've seen this all the
time and things like squares and you
know rectangles if I were to draw a
rectangle like that all right a
rectangle is made up of a bunch of
perpendicular lines
or lines at 90-degree angles so example
these two lines are at a 90 degree angle
the way you draw a 90 degree angle is
you draw a little box like that that's
the same thing as doing this is doing a
90 degree angle and you can even get
wider angles so if you go above 90
degrees so let me draw so let's say I
had a lines like this
so this would be I don't know I'm just
eyeballing it 135 degrees or something
like that and you could if you if you
ever want to really measure the angles
you can use something called a
protractor that's a tool maybe your
teachers can help you use that for that
would be 135 degrees and then if you had
a complete if you had it so wide that
the two lines are actually almost
forming a line then this becomes 180
degrees it's almost like one line right
this is 180 degrees and then you can
keep going you could go with the so this
if this angle here is 135 degrees you
can actually also measure this angle
right here let me do it in a different
color just to add some variety so then
this angle right here so the angles in a
circle aren't they're 360 degrees in a
circle so if this is 135 this blue and
this I don't know my colors this magenta
angle would be 360 degrees minus 135
degrees and that's equal to what that's
225 degrees is this is this magenta
angle and then we can do other things
like that so one you know that the
degrees in the circle are 360 degrees
this is important to note degrees in the
circle are 360 degrees it's also
important to know that if you just go
kind of halfway around a circle like we
did here that's 180 degrees like if you
viewed the pivot point is like let's say
right here I mean looks like just one
line and it really is but that's 180
degrees and then if you go quarter way
around the circle that's 90 degrees all
right hopefully you're getting a bit of
an intuition for for what an angle is so
now I will teach you a bunch of very
useful rules for angles clear this
so let me redraw so if I had a line like
this I like using the colors just so I
think it'd keep you from getting
completely bored and that it might not
be completely intuitive what I'm doing
but let's add an angle like that and so
let's just say you know I'm not
measuring these exactly let's say that
this is 30 degrees we know that if we go
all the way around the circle if we go
all the way around the circle we know
that that's 360 degrees all right and
that's a very ugly looking around the
circle angle that I drew so then we also
know that this this angle right here is
330 degrees right because this angle
Plus this magenta angle is going to
equal the whole circle so this is equal
to 330 degrees so the angles in the
circle so remember that the angles in a
circle or there are 360 degrees in the
circle and if if you ever played I don't
know if you if you were member you
probably don't the subscribe before you
were born where there used to be a game
called 720 and it was a skateboarding
game it was a video game and the 720 was
essentially you were you know you try to
jump your skateboard and and spin around
twice and that's why it's a 720 degrees
if you spin around if you go around in
the circle twice at 720 degrees if you
just jump and spin around once you went
360 degrees so that's where you probably
heard this in just you know popular
culture but anyway so 360 degrees in a
circle and you could imagine half a
circle is 180 degrees and so the other
important thing to realize is like we
said if we go halfway around the circle
it's 180 degrees but if we have two
angles that add up to that so let's say
I don't know if these lines were thick
enough for you to see let me draw
something
well doesn't look ideal but you get the
idea so if you have this line this angle
of whoops I'm still using my line tool
if we have this angle is I don't know
let's call it X and then this and then
this angle is y what do we know about
the relationship between x and y well we
know that this we know that the entire
angle is half of a circle right so
that's 180 degrees that's 180 degrees
this entire angle so what are angles X
and y going to add up to well X plus
trying to stay color consistent X plus y
are going to equal I don't know if I'm
color blind I think are going to equal
180 degrees or you could write you know
Y is equal to 180 minus X or X is equal
to 180 minus y but if X plus y is equal
our are equal to 180 degrees and you can
see that it makes sense that they do
they kind of if you add the two angles
you go halfway around the circle then
that tells us that x and y are and this
is a fancy word and it's just good to
commit this to memory they are
supplementary supplementary angles
supplementary supplementary
supplementary angles that's when you add
to 180 degrees now what if we had this
situation oh my god that was horrible
do a new let's I had this situation
let's see I draw two perpendicular lines
right so this is going a quarter way
around the circle all right let's say
this entire angle here this entire angle
I'm trying it really big that's 90
degrees right there perpendicular and
now if I had two angles within that so
now if I have two angles here so let's
say that this is X and this is y what do
x and y add up to well X plus y is 90
and we can say that x and y are
complementary complementary it's
important to not get confused between
the two
just remember complementary means two
angles add up to 90 degrees
supplementary means that two angles add
up to 180 degrees I'm running out of
time so I will see you in the next video